The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: OK, so
on Tuesday, Hayden
brought us up through
analysis of variance,
which had an implicit model of
the process hidden underneath.
It was mostly focused
on the idea of,
are there effects if you make
different kinds of conditions?
What we want to do
is pick up on that,
but get back to the
model a little bit more,
talk a little bit more
explicitly about ways
to express, from an
empirical point of view,
experimental data or other kinds
of run data that we might have.
So I'm going to
pick up a little bit
on this idea of modeling effects
when we've got multiple inputs.
Much of the ANOVA analysis was
described for a single input.
And then what we will do is look
at linear and quadratic models,
and other kinds of models for
fitting of that kind of data.
We'll talk a little bit about
calculation or fitting of model
coefficients, both from a fairly
powerful and general regression
idea, but also, we'll start to
build up the lingo for design
of experiments.
One advantage of a design
of experiments approach
is that there are shorthand
ways for rapidly assessing
and, in fact, building models
based on experimental data
points in the selection--
careful selection
of where you sample from your
process or your conditions.
So things like contrast will
be perhaps a new terminology
for you that summarize
a little bit what
it is we're trying
to do with some
of these design of
experiments, or DOE.
So to pick up a little
bit, here's, again,
the injection molding data.
We've looked at
this from a number
of different perspectives,
and we'll look at it
a little bit more today.
So we've got some
dimension that we're
measuring with an
injection molding, where
we have a couple of
different parameters--
one of which might
be the velocity
that we're using
for the injection.
Another may be the whole time.
Perhaps these are minutes--
one minute, two minute.
And one would ask, is there
an effect from a point of view
of ANOVA?
And then we can look and
compare things like the spread
within that particular
condition, say, at one minute--
compare this spread and its mean
to this spread and its mean,
and make some assessment
of whether there
is a statistically
significant effect.
But we might also
want to build up
a causal relationship,
and actually
a functional relationship
between hold time
and dimension.
And then the question
becomes, well,
what do we use to fit
such a set of data with?
Would we fit it with a line?
Would we fit it with a curve
that looks something like that,
a curve something like that?
What is appropriate?
What are appropriate
kinds of functions
to use for fitting
of these things?
Now, hopefully you've
got some intuition.
And I'm not going to try to
destroy any of that intuition
today.
I'm just going to
try to extend it.
One question for you--
hopefully you have
an intuitive feel--
would you be justified in
fitting this blue curve,
in most cases, to this data?
Well, I've now made
it a red curve.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE] a
physical model, or something,
[INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Good--
because usually the answer
is it depends, and you already
got the depends in there.
If all you had was the
pure data, certainly,
you've only got really
two sample points,
so all you can fit is a line.
But your intuition
is very good there.
If you have a lot of
physical knowledge
that, in fact, the relationship
would have to be parabolic,
two data points might give
you enough information
to be able to justifiably fit
some more complicated function.
We're going to be
mostly focusing
on empirical data and just sort
of the limits of what you can
infer from the data although.
We're not going to
be, at least today,
trying to mix in both
the physical functional
dependencies and empirical.
So one key question
then is, what
functional form might be
justified by the data?
In this case, if I've
only got two data points,
maybe it's only a very
simple linear model.
If I had more
data, well, I might
have enough to fit parabolic or
other, more complicated data.
But in addition now, when we
start to go to two inputs--
this is this is, in
fact, the same data,
where we have not
only hold time,
as we did on the
previous screen,
but we may also be
playing with the velocity
and then doing some number of
replicates-- something like 14
or 15 runs at the low
condition for velocity
and low condition
for hold time--
and then measure the data.
And what we have
here is conditions
where we've changed both
of those conditions,
and it may well be the case
that these two inputs interact--
that the effective
velocity gets amplified
when I've got a longer hold
time than a shorter hold time.
So it's not necessarily
just an additive model.
So we also need to mix in this
issue of interaction, when
we start thinking
about model form--
not just sort of the functional
dependence terms of powers
or for the shape of the
dependence on a single input,
but also when we have
multiple inputs, if there
are interactions between them.
So we can also turn
this question around.
I can say, depending on how much
data I have, what kind of model
might I fit?
Can turn it around
and say, I would
like to be able to fit a model
up to a certain kind of form--
you can turn it around
and ask the question,
what data points do I need?
How much data do
I need, and what's
the location of
those data points
in order to be able to fit
different functional forms?
And that becomes the
design of the experiment
in order to be able to meet your
modeling or estimation needs.
So what we'll be
doing is dealing
with some models of
the process, where
we have multiple inputs
or multiple treatments--
not just different conditions
or levels at these, but in fact,
we may have multiple
different kinds of treatments,
such as the velocity
and the hold time.
And so in general, we
might talk about processes
that have k input.
So in our previous
case, we had two inputs.
And then we can look at
different combinations
of the data, depending
on how many levels
we pick for each
of those inputs.
So a level is
simply where you're
sampling along that axis of
that particular factor or input.
And we'll be talking especially
about full factorial models,
where we're looking
at every combination
of the discrete selection of
those levels for those factors
that we're interested in.
So if I've got a two
level selection or choice
for each of our factor
levels, then, in general,
we can have 2 to
the k combinations
of different discrete
sample points,
different discrete
treatment sets.
You can extend this, of course.
You might be looking at tree
level experiments for each
of our factor, and then I would
have 3 to the k combinations.
And you'll detect a
trend here that's not
especially encouraging.
What happens as k gets big?
We have exponential
growth in the number
of experimental
points that we need.
Similarly, as the
number of levels go up,
you can fit more
powerful models,
but again, you need a lot
more data fairly rapidly.
Today we'll be just
pretty much focusing
on relatively simple
small numbers of k
and small numbers of level.
In fact, traditional
2 to the k design
is what we'll be
talking the most about.
When you get back
from spring break,
we'll also come back
to clever approaches
out of design of experiments
for subsampling the space--
basically, not having to
explore all of the combinations
because, in fact, all
of the combinations
may give you more data and fit a
more powerful model than you're
even really interested in.
If I were doing,
say, a 3 to the k,
I might be able to
actually estimate
all kinds of very subtle
three-factor interactions
or four-factor interactions,
but I might actually not
believe they exist.
I may had prior knowledge
they don't exist.
And so we'll look at
reduced models next time.
There is kind of just
a general question.
Why would you even want to model
or use more than one input?
Why wouldn't you want to
simplify your process,
make it as simple as possible?
Why might more than
one input be especially
important for manufacturing
process control?
These are fairly obvious,
so don't overthink too much.
Why would you need
more than one input?
AUDIENCE: Because you have more
than one input in the world--
DUANE BONING: You have more than
one input in the real world.
Why do you have more than
one input in the real world?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] complex.
You can manipulate them
in a number of ways,
so [INAUDIBLE] process might
have temperature and pressure,
different chemical baths
you could use, [INAUDIBLE]
processing.
DUANE BONING: Good.
AUDIENCE: So they all create
slightly different outputs,
but [INAUDIBLE] very similar
outputs at the same time.
DUANE BONING: Yes.
OK, so I think you've touched
on both of them there,
as a freeform spoke.
One is you often have
more than one output.
So it would actually
be odd if you
were trying to achieve
just one parameter-- say,
a length parameter-- with
a dozen different inputs
all at once.
In fact, that would be a really
challenging design problem.
Often, they do interact,
but very often,
what you're actually
after are fairly
good solid one-to-one
correspondences where,
if I play with this knob, I have
good control over this output.
So you often strive for
almost univariate, very simple
direct control.
You can't always achieve
that, and so often you've
got a multiple input
and multiple output
problem with interactions.
But even if you
only had one output,
you might actually want two
inputs, because one of them
may actually give you control
over the mean of the parameter
and another input might let
you deal with, or compensate
for, or generate, or change
the variance of the process.
And so it's actually
very nice to be
able to deal with the
process robustness,
to be able to freely recenter
the process without changing
your variance, for example.
So just highlighting that the
practical world-- you often do
have more than one input, and
there are good reasons where
you can actually use those.
So we're going to mostly be
dealing with empirical models
here, and here's an
example of a fairly simple
general linear model.
Question?
Is there a question
from Singapore?
Somebody maybe
pushed their button?
[INAUDIBLE] like
the microphone was--
we got a close-up view of you.
We know you're awake, though--
good.
OK, so here's just a quick
overview of the kind of models
that we'll be looking at.
We've got some output.
Here it's expressed
in a univariate case.
We'll extend this to
multiple outputs in a minute.
But I might have
a single output,
and the true value
here may be eta.
Again, I'm using a little bit
the Greek to indicate truth,
if you will.
And it's got some overall mean.
We might model that with
a single coefficient,
some beta 0.
And then it's got single
factor direct dependencies
on some x sub i input.
So x sub i here is indicating
which factor it is.
So I might have x1 and x2
would be a two-factor--
two different kinds
of input, sort of
like our injection
molding problem.
I might have a direct
linear dependence
and coefficient
on each of those.
And then we'll also be looking
at interaction terms, ways
of looking at a synergistic
effect between the two
of these terms--
still first-order.
These are only direct x1,
x2 kinds of interactions,
but we'll see that actually
gives you quite a bit of power
for dealing with some
interesting behavior.
Then we'll also talk about
are these higher order terms.
So in truth, the model may have
a more complicated functional
dependence.
What we're hoping
is, in many cases,
that the linear
version of the model
captures most of the behavior,
and that these higher
order model terms
are smaller effects.
And so often, we'll actually
be ignoring these higher order
terms, absorbing whatever errors
there are as a result of that,
and referring to those as a
model form or model structure
error, and distinguish
that from residual error
or other kinds of
experimental error,
or just replication error.
So let's see-- couple other
definitions just that we've got
in here--
in here, you'll notice
the k subscript indicates
the number of factors, just
like we were describing before--
two-factor, three-factor
kinds of experiments.
And then we often are forming
sums over some particular--
either factor or input
levels within those factors.
So I'll try to be a little bit
careful on what we've got then.
So with that simple
two-order or two input model,
where k is equal
to 2 in this case,
we've got something
that we might
try to use with our
injection molding case.
That was a two input model--
injection velocity
and hold time.
We've got four coefficients.
Quick question
for you-- how many
data points do
you think you need
at least a minimum of in order
to be able to fit those four
coefficients?
If I did just one experiment
and got one output,
would that be enough data to
estimate four coefficients?
No.
Four?
Or was that just a
wave of your hand?
AUDIENCE: No.
DUANE BONING: It was close.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DUANE BONING: So this
is a simple extension
of that linear case.
If you had only one input
and you wanted to fit a line,
you would need at
least two data points.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: Because
that's a zero--
DUANE BONING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
relative to your [INAUDIBLE]??
DUANE BONING: Yes.
That's a good point.
So if these are
normalized in some way,
such that there is
a 0 in between, such
that also the average
of these are 0,
then this would be the mean.
So this would be more general--
some offset term.
It may not necessarily be the
mean-- good point, good point.
OK, so part of the question is
I think there's-- it's fairly
clear intuition that you're
probably going to need at least
four data points in order to be
able to fit a four-coefficient
model.
We need at least that
number, but there
are some additional subtleties.
In this case, we've got
at least two factors,
so we know we've got two
factors at work here.
And I've got to at
least sample across both
of those input factors of both
of those treatment things.
But then there's a
question, especially
with this crazy
interaction term--
how many levels do you
really need in each case?
Notice also here that, if I
only have four data points,
there's no way for me to really
estimate higher order terms.
And we'll also
chat a little bit,
because if I have
exactly four data points,
it's also not easy for
me to estimator terms,
because if I have four data
points, I can exactly fit--
I get a direct solution
for the four coefficients.
And I can perfectly fit those--
I may be wrong in terms
of actually interpolating
between those, but I
have a direct solution
for those four coefficients.
So part of the
thing we'll get at
is, how might you select
levels and data samples
so that you have more
data to be able to do
additional inferences
on your model--
things like, what is the
actual confidence level I
have that an effect is real?
What's my estimation not just
on a point estimate for a model
coefficient-- a beta
0 here or a beta 1--
but also, what is
an integral estimate
for those kinds of coefficients?
So we'll get to many
of those things.
OK, here's back to our
injection molding case--
dimension versus old time.
I might try to fit that with
a very simple one input linear
model, some offset beta 0 and
some beta 1 linear dependence.
And we've already said
it looks like I'm going
to need at least two levels.
I'm going to label those with an
x underscore minus and an x sub
plus--
so a high level and a low level.
We'll actually talk about
different labeling strategies
for these things that make
some of the calculations
a little bit easier.
So if I, again,
do just one trial
at each level, what I've got--
there's a little bit
more notation for us
in very simple vector notation--
what I've got is one
factor, two levels,
if I'm just doing
a one-input model.
So what I will have is
two measurements, an eta 1
and an eta 2.
Those are my two
actual sample points.
And what I've done is run them
at two different conditions.
So in fact, these indicate
the two different conditions
that I ran at.
And what I'm trying to do is
fit the beta 0 and the beta 1
for this case.
Now, because I've got exactly
the right amount of data,
I'm going to have to
estimate that the noise is 0,
as we'll see in just a second.
Now, I can express the
two sets of samples--
so I've got,
basically, an eta 1 is
equal to some beta 0 plus
beta 1x at the low condition.
And I've, similarly, got eta 2.
I'm estimating as beta 0 plus
beta 1 at the high condition.
That's just a system
of two equations
I can write it in matrix
form, as shown down here.
So I've got this condition
times my two coefficient.
So I've got my beta
0 and my beta 1.
That's my first equation,
giving me my eta 1--
and similarly, for my eta 2.
Now, since we've got exactly
the same number of model
coefficients and model
runs, my x is square,
and I've got a direct
solution to this equation--
where, again, eta is 0, because
I don't have any replicates,
I don't have any noise,
and so I can simply
directly invert that and solve
directly for my coefficient.
So my purpose here
was both to remind us
that there is some vector
notation that just follows what
you would think of naturally,
and in the special case
where you've only got exactly
just barely enough data,
there's a direct solution.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
But what we'd
often like to do is
remember that there's
noise in our process--
that, if I were to, in fact,
run at the same condition
multiple times, I've probably
got some variance in there.
It may be measurement error.
It may be underlying
process variation.
So what do we do when
we've got replicates?
First off, we probably
want to design
the process or the experimental
design for the process
so that we do
sample at multiple--
at the same condition
multiple times
so we can estimate
these variances.
I'm going to need that
information for things
like confidence intervals
on the coefficients.
So how do we deal
with data where
there is some spread,
even at the same factor
level for hold time?
Well, now we're into
an over-specified set
of linear equations.
I've got multiple sets of
data for the same input.
I've got multiple y's.
I got multiple outputs.
And what we'll
generally be doing
is trying to do our best fit in
the same intuitive way you've
probably been doing regression
modeling or fitting of lines
to data for a long time.
We have a general
approach of trying
to get the best fit in
a conceptual approach
of minimizing some error metric.
The most standard one is a
sum of squared deviations
of your data from
your prediction.
So we often talk about
least squares or minimum
squared error data sets.
So in those kinds of conditions,
what we're trying to do
is find the data not and
the one that gives us
the best line that, in aggregate
across all of our data,
minimizes the sum of all squared
error terms, where each error
term--
each e sub i is--
so this would be
my e sub i term.
When I ran run sub
i for input at,
let's say, level 1 for
my single factor here.
This is my prediction.
This is my data.
So I've got a deviation
between my best prediction
at that input level and
my actual measurement.
I'm squaring that, and
then what we're looking at
is the sum of all of those
across all of my data.
And you can formulate it as sort
of that optimization problem
and do a search for the best
beta 0, beta 1, conceptually.
Turns out, in the
simple linear cases,
the power of linear models
is that one can still
solve the matrix formulation
of the problem using
a pseudo-inverse in the
over-specified case, where
I've got multiple samples
at the same condition.
And we need to do
that, because now,
if I've got multiple
rows where I've
sampled the same
conditions multiple times,
my x matrix is no
longer square, so I
can't do a direct solution.
There's an aside
here, which is simply
the derivation of this
relationship, this beta
solution, based on the minimum
squared error condition.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
For the previous
equation, isn't it
beta 0 plus beta 1 time x based
on beta 0 minus beta 1 time x?
DUANE BONING: Good.
Yeah.
I guess I could change
the sign in the middle,
but I probably
shouldn't do that.
Yeah, that should
probably be a plus there.
Thank you.
So we could, again,
formulate our problem just
to give you a quick
sense of where
that funky description of this--
using this pseudo-inverse idea
comes from.
Again, if I have
my linear model,
I can express based
on my measured data.
These are my
different conditions
and these are my model terms.
I've got a way to express
the error for all of my runs,
and now the squared error
can be written in matrix form
as the transpose of that error
vector times the error vector.
And now I simply
substitute in, and you
get something like that.
And now you can
do the derivative.
What we're looking
for is the point
at which this quadratic
error is minimum.
So I can do the derivative
there, and at that point,
I'm looking for the bottom
of that squared error
curve, that quadratic error--
which, if I differentiate
this, I get this.
And now I can simply
solve, and then,
when you go ahead and plug
that in, that drives for us--
this funky thing, where you
take your data condition
x transpose x, then
you do the inverse
of that times the x transpose
with your measured outputs
to solve for beta.
So there is a matrix
algebra formulation here
that's basically giving us
the best minimum error fit
for all of our data.
So that's a very nice, powerful
general linear regression
result.
Here's another picture
of the same thing.
This is the same idea-- not the
derivation, but what I meant
by when I've got replicates.
Again, this is my
measured vector.
These are my conditions.
Again, I'm either running
at the low condition
or at the high condition
for each of my--
for my single input here.
I've got two coefficients,
so my x times my beta,
again, gives me my beta 0 plus
my either x high or x low times
beta 1.
And for each case, I get
some measured output.
And the point is now,
if I have replicates--
there's an x low, here's another
x low, and if I continued on,
there may be multiple places
where my conditions were
exactly the same--
oops-- my coefficients
are exactly the same,
but I get different
measured outputs.
So that's how my--
what used to be my square
matrix becomes non-square.
I'm filling in additional data
rows as I add more replicates.
And so in that case, I still
got the simple linear model,
but now I have to use
not a direct inverse,
but I got to use this
sort of pseudo-inverse
in order to fit my
beta coefficients.
OK, so that's the very powerful,
general linear regression
kind of approach, and it's based
on minimizing a squared error
term.
But there's a lot
more intuitive way
of looking at this and some
other observations that
make estimation easier,
and also connect up,
I think, very nicely
with our intuition.
One important point is, when
I've only got two levels--
so our one input, two levels--
we know a line has
to fit that data.
And if I've got
replicates, the line
actually has to go through--
provably, and we'll see a
very quick little derivation--
the line has to go
through the mean at each
of the data points,
my replicate points,
at each of my two levels.
So in order to fit
the data, one is
you could put it
all on a big matrix
and send it off to
Matlab, or Excel,
or whatever to do this
big matrix pseudo-inverse,
or you can simply
calculate, look at your data
under your low condition, your
data under your high condition,
find the mean, and
your line has to go
through the mean of
those two conditions.
So one of the two might be a
little bit easier on a quiz.
And this is simply working
out and showing you,
if, in this simple two-input
condition, where I only
had two data points, then
you could see how this works.
But with the mean,
what's very nice
is now this is the
mean of my output,
and what that gives you is
a direct expression using
that fact to be able to
calculate your offset term
and your beta 1 term.
Let me see.
Am I going to do this yet?
No.
So here's a simple application
of that for our real data,
this injection molding case.
Here now I'm doing
something kind of sneaky.
This is I'm treating all
of that injection molding
experimental design
as if I'd only
done an experimental
design in hold time.
So what's really hidden
inside of this spread of data
is it is all replicates
at the low value x minus
for hold time.
Similarly, these are
replicates at x plus,
but they're not really
good pure replicates,
because other things
were changing.
First off, time might
often be changing,
but what was going on
in here is I was also
playing with the injection
velocity at the same time.
So in this case,
this is saying I'm
going to treat these
other things that
might be changing, like
injection velocity,
as just noise factors.
They're what contributes to
the spread at the condition
that I'm actually interested in.
And so you will often do that.
I'm just trying to
fit a very simple
first-order linear model, just
relating my one factor here
of hold time to my output.
And it's going to have
some variance and error
in my estimate because of
all these other higher order
terms that I'm not including,
other factors that I'm not
including, pure replication
error, measurement error.
But what I am trying
to do is understand
as closely as possible the
effective that single factor.
So very often, I really do
want to know just the hold time
effect fact, even when it's
contaminated with or spread out
with these other effects.
This is just showing,
for that actual data,
I can fit my two
means for the spread,
and then fit a very
simple linear model.
Now, in this case,
I'm treating hold time
as kind of a continuous
factor, so you might think,
if these are hold
time in minutes,
now you can interpolate.
And I could ask,
what I think the hold
time-- or the effective
on my dimension
might be at 1.5 minutes?
So I'm interpolating
within my data.
I could also extrapolate
and ask questions.
Well, what do I think it'll
be out here at 2.5 minutes?
That might be a
little bit risky,
and we'll talk about
that a little bit
in a later lecture, when we talk
about the confidence intervals.
But at another
point I want to make
is this same picture
would apply even if these
weren't continuous parameters.
And I find it easier to think
about the problem in terms
of continuous parameters,
because you're often
changing a pressure, or a
velocity, or a hold time,
and looking at a continuous
variation in some output
parameter.
But a very important point
that I do want to make here is,
if I were to use exactly the
same chart and relabel the axes
and say something like,
this is the dimension--
this is still dimension--
and I'm doing injection
molding, but here I'm
using it from a tool from
different manufacturers.
So here, I run the tool on--
I don't know-- Fritze Inc's
injection molding tool,
and over here it's
on Xenon Corp's tool.
I could have essentially the
same model, the same formalism
if these were discrete
levels, discrete choices
in some factor.
Here my factor is,
which choice of tool
would I want to be making?
I want to know, is
there an effect?
I maybe even want to build a
model with model coefficients
for the effect, depending
on what factor level I pick.
Now, if these were
discrete choices,
it no longer makes sense to
interpolate or extrapolate,
but I do want to just highlight
that the same formalism--
especially for
factorial designs--
applies to both
continuous parameters
and discrete parameters.
I'm going to come back
to that a little bit
when we talk about what might--
slightly different ways
of looking at the model
coefficients be in those cases.
But I just want to
remind you or highlight
that you can use these for both
continuous and discrete kinds
of designs and factors.
OK, so continuing
with our plan here--
we've talked about multiple
inputs and effects--
what I want to do next is say,
if I do have multiple inputs,
how does our ANOVA
formalism apply
to being able to decide
whether both factors matter,
or not, or three factors,
which factors actually matter.
And based on my
observations, do I
think that that factor
actually has an effect or not?
So I want to derive
first real quickly,
or show for us the
different ANOVA
formalisms in these cases.
And then we'll come
back a little bit more
to the estimation of
these model coefficients.
Oh, what happened?
There we go.
OK.
So back to our injection
molding problem,
now with two factors,
where we have the velocity
and we have the hold time--
and this is where I said I
was being a little bit sneaky
when I was showing you
the one factor data.
In fact, the setup here was to
do four different combinations
of these two factors--
two-factor, two-level
experimental design--
with replicates at each factor--
something like 14
or 15 replicates.
And here nothing was
intentionally changing,
so these are more
like pure replicates
within that set of
experimental conditions.
And what we can do is look
at, in that case, where I've
got pure replicates,
what is the average
at that test condition--
so test condition 1,
where it was low and low
for the two factors, and so on
for test condition 2, 3, and 4.
And now we can
ask the question--
not just in the univariate case,
but in the multivariate case,
what kind of model works?
And this is actually
a description
of the model that might be
more appropriate if they
were discrete choices
and you weren't
trying to do interpolation.
But it's also
implicitly the model
that we're using
for ANOVA analysis,
because the ANOVA
doesn't care whether it's
a continuous parameter
or a discrete parameter
that we're using.
So the basic idea for a two--
this is a two-factor
kind of model.
This is very close to what we
saw with the ANOVA on Tuesday.
One of the factor might be--
or treatment effect that
we might be looking for
might be the velocity effect.
The other might be
the hold time effect,
and then we may be looking for
interactions between the two.
And the picture you
should have in your mind
is that what we're
going to try to do
is model this with
an overall mean--
some mu-- and then we're
asking the question--
think back to the
ANOVA question--
is there a deviation
from the grand mean,
from the overall mean, if I have
velocity at the high condition?
Is there a statistically
significant shift
up for a high setting?
And similarly, is there a
statistically significant
low effect?
So is there an up or
down shift, depending on
whether I pick the high or
low condition for velocity?
And similarly, I would ask the
question, is there an effect--
a beta 1 effect or
a beta 2 effect--
depending on whether
I selected the low--
I guess this is the
high-- the high condition
or the low condition for
that actual variable?
So these are discrete
offsets, depending
on whether I was at the
low or the high condition.
So i indicates, in
our earlier notation,
either the plus or minus.
Here, we're switching
rotation a little bit
to just be a numerical index--
either 1 or 2 in
this case, but if I
had multiple levels of that
factor, I could extend that.
I can have little deltas
with a coefficient that
would go for each delta,
depending on the discrete value
that I picked for that level.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What if it's
a shift of variance,
and not a shift in the
mean altering one of them?
DUANE BONING: It's
a good question.
The question was, what if
it's a shift in variance?
Here we are looking for just--
we're just modeling the mean
value of the output with this.
You could similarly start
looking at building up
models of variance.
You would probably
not be thinking of it
as additive variance
terms in those cases,
so you might also end up
doing some other kinds
of transformations
on your data to get
to additive models of variance.
But basically, if
I had enough data,
you could start to
try to model variance.
If you think back to
the ANOVA formulation,
the simple ANOVA is all
assuming your variance
is exactly the same across
all of your conditions.
There are wonderful books
on more powerful modeling
and how ANOVA extends to those.
In fact, one of my favorites--
I lent it to Hayden--
is a book by George
Milliken, the title of which
is Analysis of Messy Data.
And it deals with all kinds
of wonderful conditions--
not only modeling of
variance, but also
when you've got very
complicated design situations
with partially replicated,
data unbalanced design.
You run the whole
experimental design and you're
missing a data point, because
the experiment crashed--
what do you do now?
Looks at every possible thing--
so here, we're really looking
just at mean modeling.
Just to finish this
up, I should also
point out that there would be
discrete offsets, depending
on every combination of our
interaction factors as well.
And so I might have discrete
model terms for those as well.
Now, an important point
just to make here is that,
in this kind of a model-- and
it'll maybe become clearer
a little bit later--
each of these model
coefficients--
this tau 1 and a tau 2 effect,
for example, for the velocity--
they're not really independent.
And this gets back to, I
think, your question about,
in this model, this--
if I were modeling
that as a beta 0 term,
this really is
the mean, and that
imposes an additional
linear constraint
on my other coefficients.
And in particular,
that tau 1 and tau 2
would have to be equal
and opposite here.
This is a great model for being
able to conceptualize and plug
in, depending on what
factor levels you have.
You just have to be careful
in fitting the model,
and recognize that, in
this kind of a formulation,
there's some implied
dependencies within this--
in particular, that each
of the factor levels--
factor effects have
to be 0 mean overall,
and the interaction
terms, similarly,
have to be, in
aggregate, 0 mean.
That kind of makes
sense, because--
think of the case where I've
got two inputs, two outputs--
or one output, got
my two factors--
velocity and hold time-- and I'm
just doing two levels for each.
I've got four
different conditions.
I may have replication,
but I've only
got four different conditions.
How could I possibly fit a
mean, two taus for factor 1,
two coefficients-- taus for--
or betas here for factor 2,
and four interaction terms?
That's four, five,
six, seven, eight--
nine model coefficients,
four data points.
So clearly, there's got to be
some additional constraints
on the model coefficients
hidden under that.
OK, so that's one way of looking
at the experimental design
and the data.
Here's another way,
simply pointing out--
what we'll often be
doing is building tables
to show the high
and low condition
for our different
factors and the levels.
We might label those,
and then often, we'll
illustrate our design
space or experimental space
with a design matrix
or a design plot.
So here I'm showing simply--
the four different conditions
for velocity and hold
time either, low or high.
and I'm also doing something
a little bit subtle,
which is labeling them with
not just a plus or a minus,
but in fact, giving them a
normalized value of plus 1
or minus 1.
There's some subtle
reasons for doing that.
One is, by definition, when
I now fit for a two-level
experiment--
when I fit a model
coefficient to that,
it will always be
0 mean, and so now
that beta 0 term really does
turn into the mean estimate.
But-- might see that
a little bit later.
But the point is here
now this is basically
expressing all four of my
conditions, my test conditions
from the previous design.
And I can also plot that, each
one of these test conditions,
on the x1 axis.
We said this is
velocity, basically.
And this is my x2 axis,
which is hold time.
So it's either at the plus
1 or the minus 1 level
for that factor.
And so I've got an
experimental design,
where I've got
four sample points
at the plus minus
every combination
of those particular factors.
And so we'll often talk
about this as a corner
point DOE or a
full factorial DOE,
where I've got every combination
of those discrete factor
levels being mapped out.
And then I go and
I run my tests.
And here I've just
written down the results
of the average of the
output over all replicates
for that point.
So this was over the
14 or 15 replicates.
Notice here, this is just
mapping out the design space,
my x1 versus x2.
It's not really showing you on
a third axis what the output is.
We could also do that
and have a 3D plot,
and we'll see that in a second.
But the point for doing this
formulation, this full effects
model with these
effects offsets and just
reminding us what the
model exploration here
is, is that what we
would also like to do,
even when I've got
more than one factor--
I've got these x1
and x2 factors--
is ask the ANOVA
question, which would be--
from an ANOVA point of
view, I would like to ask,
does velocity have an effect?
If I change from
the low to the high,
do I get an appreciable
and significant change
in the output?
So from an ANOVA point
of view, if I'm just
looking at velocity, I would
like to ask a question--
just looking together
across all of the data
that I've got at the
low condition for x1
and all of the data from
the condition at x2,
I might ask that
question and say,
is there a shift from
that perspective or not?
So really, we're back
to a hypothesis test--
oh, what happened there?
This should be a dot, dot, dot.
[INAUDIBLE]---- which is
basically asking the question,
in the null hypothesis,
there is no effect--
all of my taus are equal and 0,
and all my interactions are 0.
And in the alternative
hypothesis,
something has an effect.
So that's the key question.
Now, what you can do is
start formulating, exactly
like we did with ANOVA,
sums of squared deviations
across, for example,
all of the A levels
averaged over the B
factors and any replicates.
Remember, this is replicates.
This is the B factor.
So for example, this sum
right here would be--
let's see-- forgot which one--
I'm looking at the responses
for the first level,
so call it the A level.
So that would be basically
the big red thing
that I had drawn here.
I basically call this
first one factor A,
and what I'm simply
doing is averaging over
all of the n replicates
at each of these points
and over the B
levels at that point.
So I can form a sum of squared
set of deviations from the mean
as I change factor
A. I can similarly
do that as I change factor B.
Then I can also look
at these interaction
sum of squared terms,
and once I have these,
I can now start to
break down the total sum
of squared deviations in my data
into components due to factor
A, sum of squares from--
deviations from the grand
mean for factor B, and terms
here from interactions.
And then this is residuals,
sum of squared error.
So basically, it's just like
we did with the single factor
ANOVA, but now I can do that,
well, looking and seeing,
did factor A have an effect?
What's the sum of
squared deviations
that I observed in
my data from the mean
as I change that factor--
and similarly, for
factor B. And I
could extend this
on to more factors,
if I wanted-- if I had
three factors or four.
This is also just
reminding us or laying out
that there are different degrees
of freedom in each case, which
we're going to need
when we want to estimate
the mean square,
because what we'll do
is we'll take the sum
of squared deviations,
divide it by its
degrees of freedom--
which is the number of
factor levels I had minus 1
in each of those cases--
and put these together to
get a mean square estimate
for that factor,
which is essentially
an estimate of the variance
due to changing factor A,
just like in the
ANOVA formulation.
And you can plot that
into an ANOVA table
for multiple factors,
where, again, we
have the sum of
squared deviations
due to each of those factors.
This is just plugging in those
formulas that we saw earlier.
And the interaction-- if I've
got pure replicates, that's
a great case where I can
separate out exactly just
the replication
error, perhaps coming
from measurement or pure
process replication error.
And then, with the right
appropriate degree of freedom,
I can now form the
mean square estimates.
Remember, these are
variance estimates.
And then I can form the
right F factor to decide,
does this mean square,
with respect to my
within group mean square--
is that large
enough effect to be
statistically significant
using an F-test?
So it's exactly the same
formulation for the ANOVA,
but now where we
can break it out
across multiple factors
or multiple interactions.
OK.
You actually have to try
it and use this to get it,
but the key point
here is, when we
are building these
multiple factor models,
it's still an ANOVA formalism
to decide whether or not
that factor is statistically
significant or not.
So let's look at this in
the case of a linear model.
And I'm going to give you a
little bit more terminology
here and start to get to
this idea of contrasts, which
are easy ways of estimating
some of these models.
So this is still our
injection molding data.
Factor x1 here was velocity.
This was hold time.
And I've got every combination.
What's new on this page that I
want to draw your attention to
is some additional
terminology that we often
use that's shorthand
for indicating
the different combinations
of those factor levels, that
tell us exactly what
point, what condition,
combination we're running
for each of our tests.
So I already showed
you this table
which was saying, OK,
for my first factor--
which we've also
labeled as factor A--
factor x2 is our second factor.
So note here, we've got
three different kinds
of-- ways of referring
to the same factor.
The first factor,
factor a x1 value--
it's the velocity term.
What I can also do is
indicate in shorthand which
condition is actually at work.
And so it takes a little
bit of getting used to,
but what you'll see here is--
let's look at this
condition first.
What I've selected here
for test number two
is the high condition
for factor A
and the low condition
for factor B.
So what we're doing
in shorthand is
indicating with a lowercase
version of that factor level
all of the high selections
for that factor.
So the high here meant I
picked the high condition
for factor A, and I denote
that with a little a.
And the low factors we
just leave off, or think
of those as a 1 setting.
So my high condition
for factor B--
I'll indicate that test setup
as-- with a little low b.
And this interaction,
where I vary and pick
the high condition
for both of those,
gives me the AB combination.
And the overall low
condition we often refer to
as the 1 test condition.
Now, the reason for
doing this will maybe not
be completely clear, but--
give you some intuition.
When we extend this to larger
numbers of factors, where
you want a very shorthand way of
describing which combination--
which test condition, which
combination of your factor
levels you want to do,
and as ways of forming
sums on the outputs
at those conditions
in order to be able
to do our estimates.
So that's a little bit
of additional notation.
Now, the model that
we might want to fit
is, in fact, perhaps
a regression model.
It's a little bit different
than the factor effects model,
which becomes a very
nice way to do it
when we've normalized
our inputs.
This works best with
normalized input levels--
in other words, my x sub i
taking on values of plus 1
and minus 1.
And we'll see how those relate
to the offset or effects model
in a second.
So this is now the same plot,
my input x1 and my input x2,
but now I'm also
adding the output.
So I'm getting to my
3D view of the results.
This is the same
graph as before--
my factor A and my factor B.
But then the height
here-- each of the values
is the y bar at my n
replicates averaged together
to give me a sense of
what my actual process
output was at each of my
four input conditions.
So we can talk about
here the mean values
of each of those different
treatment conditions,
again, where each of those
is an output across those.
And now we can start
to look and say,
OK, are there trends as
a function of factor A,
are there trends as a
function of factor B,
and fit model
coefficients that go
or capture with those trends?
So a couple more pieces of
terminology-- we can be asking,
is there an effect
in the ANOVA sense--
and we don't want
to estimate what
the effective is from a
model coefficient effect--
is there an affect
or a main effect--
which is the direct
linear term--
and are there these
interaction effects,
or these AB interaction or
multiple factor interactions?
And the perspective that
we take is very close
now to that sneaky
trick that I showed--
described with the
injection molding data.
If I'm trying to estimate the
main effective my first factor,
I basically am treating
my second factor
as just noise conditions.
And I form my aggregate
perspective for,
is there a velocity
effect, averaging together
all of the other
data, just considering
holding the velocity at its
low condition or the velocity
at its high condition.
And then I basically
do a linear fit
through the mean
of those two cases.
So it's just like we were
doing that the linear case,
but ignoring or lumping
together all of the other data
to estimate the main
effect in each case.
So there's a way to look
at this then in our data
here for estimating
the main effect.
We would label the
main effect for A
as basically looking and
saying, what I'd like to do
is take both of my
high settings for A--
this is the plus setting for A--
average the outputs together
for those two cases--
similarly, take the
low condition for A--
let me use a slightly different
color here, make this blue--
look at the low condition,
and average those together,
and then look at
in aggregate as I
went from the low to the
high for condition A.
Is there an average jump up?
Is there an effect of
factor A in aggregate?
And so what you can actually
do is very simply form--
or model that overall
delta coming from factor A
as just the overall average
between these two points
and the overall average
between these two points,
and simply fit the line through
the mean of those two cases.
So essentially, I
project all of my data
just down onto my A axis and
ask the univariate question,
does my y output change
as a function of A--
lumping together all
of the other data?
And so that's simply what
we're doing with this equation.
And now that terminology that
I introduced in the earlier
picture comes into play.
You can talk about now
the outputs at y sub
A high as being
those cases where
I had the plus value for
A and the low value for B.
And the other one would
be the plus value for A
and the high condition
for B. So these two points
I'm simply referring to--
it's getting kind of
messy here, isn't it?
I can refer to
this average right
here as the A and
AB outputs averaged.
I've got two of those
levels, and then n
replicates at each
of those points.
So that's just a way of
expressing that average,
using our test
condition terminology.
OK.
Everybody get mean effects?
We can also do
interaction effects.
And they're a little bit more
subtle to form the contrast,
but it's essentially asking
a different set of averages,
and trying to say, as I
change both A and B together,
do I get something more than the
A effect alone or the B effect
alone?
And what we actually do in this
case is take the AB condition--
this one right here--
take the low-- so I'm taking
the high-high and the low-low,
forming its average.
Then I take the other corner,
the just A high and the just B
high--
take its average, and then
basically take the difference
between those two.
So I'm averaging the
corners together,
in contrast to the main
effect, where I just averaged
along the two factor levels.
And that forms an
estimate of the AB offset.
Basically, this average
of the A high and the A
low we'll refer to as the
contrast, the right combination
of the output
values that give me
an estimate for the A effect.
And similarly, we'll talk
about the contrast here
for the B factor.
Which combinations
of output values
do you use to estimate that
effect and the contrast
for the interaction terms?
And what's cool, if I go back to
that early slide where I said,
if I'm just fitting
a linear output, y
as a function of one factor,
and I got two data points,
my line goes through the
average of those two conditions.
If I form the contrast now
in a multiple output case,
again, the best estimate
of the linear line
goes through the averages--
these are the averages at
each of those conditions.
And what I've simply
got is, directly
from the contrast,
a direct estimate
of the model coefficient as a
function in the normalized axis
space.
If our x sub i's are in
this normalized plus 1
to minus 1 range,
directly calculating
the contrast of my
outputs gives me
directly what an
estimate of the effects
are-- the main effects as well
as the interaction effects.
So I didn't actually
have to go and do
the optimization problem,
do the linear regression.
I'm using the fact that the
linear regression forces
the data to go
through the averages.
And I can simply look at the
data conditions that I've got,
the averages of the output at
each of my four combinations,
and then look at it either
from the A factor perspective
and estimate the A affect,
with a B factor perspective
and estimate the B effect,
and then also look and see
if there's an interaction
between the two
because of cross-coupling
between those two factors.
So what you've got is the
regression perspective
and this contrast perspective
are exactly the same.
Now, I said this
was a linear model,
and what's cool is it
actually is from either the A
perspective--
I guess that's the B factor.
That's the slope, if
you will, versus my B
factor, my x2 variable.
I could similarly have the
slope from my A factor.
This was my A axes, or x1 axes.
So I've got a simple
linear dependence of output
on the input in each
of those two cases,
and the interaction basically
gives me linear dependencies
that add additional offsets,
but that are locally linear
in each case.
So what we get is this
so-called 3D ruled surface that
is linear every
time I project it
on either the A
axis or the B axis.
But it's got this
kind of funky ability
to shift because
of the interaction,
so it's kind of a subtle
non-linearity at work.
It's not a curvature
non-linearity
in the sense of
quadratic curvature.
It is a ruled surface
projection down
to linear dependencies on A and
B for each of my combinations.
So here's an example
of the surface
that results if I don't
have the interaction.
And a very simple model
example is x1 and x2
with some linear
coefficient, and then
what I've simply got for my
ruled surface is a plane.
It's a slanted plane as a
function of x and x2 factors.
Sometimes we also draw
these interaction plots,
and all of that this is just
looking at one of the factors--
say, along x2-- and picking some
value for the other factor--
say, x1 is-- let's
see-- x1 is low--
that would be this
line right there--
or x1 is high, which would
be this line right there--
and then simply plotting y
just as the univariate function
of x2, where I picked or set
some other value for my x1.
And in this case
without interaction,
you'll notice those lines
have to be parallel--
that what I've got as a
simple linear additive model
without interaction
is I just get off sets
because of whatever
value of x when I pick
or offsets because of
whatever value of x2 I pick.
So this is simply
saying the x1 effect
is shown right here as an
additional shift in the output
dependence on x2.
So this is just another
slice through the 3D picture,
but what's important
here is you would
see this kind of interaction
pattern on your output
as a function of your
input, if there's
no cross term between x1 and x2.
And in contrast, here's the
response surface of output
as a function of my two inputs.
This is, again, a ruled surface.
Each one of these
is just a line,
but now it's got this
funky non-linearity because
of this interaction term.
And in this case, if I take a
slice at different low and high
of x1, you can see that
there's something at work
more than just an
additive effect from x1,
depending on my value of x2.
There is synergy between
whatever x1 value I pick
and x2 value I picked
that together--
I need both to
explain the output
and how they work together.
You can also have
negative interactions,
where the cross term causes
a negative synergistic effect
between the two.
OK, so what we'll
pick up on next time
is extending this a little
bit to a more general way
of talking about
these contrasts.
I think hopefully now
you've got the picture
from a univariate kind of
modeling and regression picture
up to a two-factor
kind of picture
with these interactions.
Next time, what we'll
do is extend that--
oops-- extend that or generalize
that to when I might have three
factors--
an A, B, and a C
factor, for example.
And how do you visualize your
design space in those cases
and how do you form the contrast
to very quickly estimate model
coefficients in those cases?
And then we'll also get to--
oops-- why'd that happen?
We'll also get next time to
looking a little bit more at,
how do I check the adequacy
of these model terms,
are they significant,
as well as,
what are good estimates
for confidence intervals
on these things-- and then come
to these other subtle points,
like what happens
if I don't want
to do 2 to the k, when k is 5?
I don't necessarily
need every combination.
And we'll talk about
fractional factorial designs.
So one thing you should do
in preparation for next time
is start reading the
experimental design chapter.
And I can't remember which
chapter it is in Montgomery.
I'll post that on the--
as an announcement
on the website.
But there's a lot of
lingo to get used to,
but it all comes back to
nice intuitive relationships,
I think.
But you do need to
start at least scanning
that chapter in Montgomery for
the experimental design stuff.
I think Montgomery has a more
thorough description than we
can find [INAUDIBLE].
Actually, [INAUDIBLE]
might be a good place
to get the quick
read on it first,
and then Montgomery
in more detail.
So with that, I hope you guys
have a great spring break.
And enjoy the MIT spring
break, for our MIT students
in Singapore.
You can rub it in to
all your classmates
who are still meeting for
other classes in Singapore.
You get a break to work on
your projects out in Singapore.
So we'll see you in two weeks.